this season of inside Conan is all about
remotes Kona remotes yeah and you did a
lot of them when you were there
um and there's they're some of people's
favorites and so you know we wanted to
talk to you about a couple of the like
the soul food remote people talk about
all the time
[Music]
yes golly yeah how did you pitch that
did someone else pitch that do you
remember
me and you I don't know if you remember
me me and him I was talking to him yeah
and so him has a name
I know you'll remember this I told you I
was like I'm going
I think it was like I think we was on
like Thanksgiving break or something
like that and I told you and you was
like how's your Thanksgiving and I said
it was great man I was like came home my
mother made some food put in some Cool
Whip bowls and brought it back and he
was like cool with bows and I was like
yeah that's what black people do we put
our food and bowls and cool with bows
almost like my mom actually has cool
whipballs yeah I know right yeah so you
put your food and then bring it back for
butternuts
squash it really is
and uh you was like laughing and we was
just laughing I was like yeah man like
yeah we got soul food
and I don't know how we started talking
but I was like what's the difference
between soul food and Southern food yeah
like I I just I kept thinking yeah yeah
and what gives it the southern because
they both the same thing basically right
and uh
I was asking us I wanted to come has
Conan never ate so because one of the
writers said they never had soul food
right and I was like that's weird and
then I was like I wouldn't have Conan
ever had and Conan said he never did oh
yeah I think you asked Conan he was like
Coney said he never had soul food and I
was like get the out of here yeah
so we was like yeah now that's how it
came about like perfect yeah yeah we
should stay coming and go get some soul
food I was like that'd be great so I
picked this place called M M's had you
been there before yeah I went there
before it was in a hood hood like Kona
should get some street cred for this
right yeah
probably like there's Lululemon yeah
no and I was late so
[Music]
full experience you know just to get
coming into it I got that he was like
yeah
it's like sorry brother sorry that's how
you got to get here you got to get here
like but we went in there man and it was
like I could couldn't believe this dude
he was just Wilding yeah he was were you
kind of just like uh sorry about my
friend I had to fall back because he was
in a world
one thing about Conan you put Conan and
what that's so great about all the
travel remotes and everything as you
know you put Conan in the world he ain't
familiar with yeah his lights out he'll
just start and he knows
he literally is like you know I had to
fall back that whole remote I think I
said maybe four things I noticed that
that I was wondering like yeah yeah that
whole remote he just when he's in a
world that he that he ain't familiar
with yeah yeah you know what's up
man I that's you are describing a
perfect I remember when we were on tour
and they were shooting that documentary
and like the second that camera would
come in he lights out lights out and and
it was just like wow you he yeah it's
like oxygen we have those cameras yeah
it's amazing it's kind of amazing yeah
and we were there and then the woman
came up hey let me get your order and
come on like yeah let me get uh this
this yeah fried bologna yeah
I ain't no fried baloney I don't know if
we can make that yeah and the Kool-Aid I
remember that cool lady dress like this
oh god oh wow I was wondering I got
diabetes
and then there was a black this is
number that eating watching them say
that yeah they got diabetes
[Laughter]
how much of the food did he actually eat
yeah
yeah you hate that like for real
you know he does like fried food I was
gonna say like he's not the most
adventurous eater but he does like
something fried oh man
yeah it was like smothered chicken
and he he yeah like we sat there and ate
that oh yeah yeah I did not ask if
you I knew he ate I just know that's
like yeah no we ate that well
because it's a there's a wipe in the
remote and I was like okay who yeah
so so it was exaggerated Church you know
how we yeah yeah you know but but did he
eat but he puts him down okay okay I'm
happy to hear that yeah he ate now it
was crazy